The Tortoise and the hare are racing to
see who can run 100 feet in the shortest
amount of time their positions and feet
as a function of time and seconds T of T
and H of T respectively are plotted
below so T of T is the position of the
tortoise as a function of time and it's
in feet H of T is the position of the
hare what is the meaning of the rate of
change of T of T on the interval T is
greater than zero and less than 20 so T
of T they were talking about the
tortoise here this is the function T of
T right over here this blue line and it
looks like it's moving at a constant
rate of change the slope of this line is
constant so let's see what this rate of
change is if we start so we can even
start from the starting position when
one second goes by each notch here in
the horizontal axis is one second you
see one two three four five so every
time he one second goes by it looks like
it looks like and we have to be very
careful here at first it looks like oh
maybe he moves one feet but we have to
be careful about what these notches
represent it looks like these notches
represent 5 10 15 20 25 feet so every
time one second goes by he moves forward
five feet another second goes by moves
forward five feet so it looks like the
tortoise the tortoise the rate of the
tortoise so I'll say the tortoise rate
the rate of the the change of distance
with respect to time is 5 feet for every
second so let's see which of our choices
seemed to match that and that is over
the entire interval the interval starts
here this is zero and 20 is right over
here and it looks like we have a
constant rate we have a constant slope
we have the same inclination of this
line the entire time all the way until T
is equal to 20 so this first choice says
the tortoise walks at 5 feet per second
the whole time and this looks right are
we our tortoise has a constant rate of 5
feet per second this walks might be
might be an understatement 5 feet per
second is a pretty good
especially for a tortoise but we are
going to go with that one now let's just
look at the other ones for fun to see
how true they are or see if they could
have somehow applied to this problem the
hare stops moving after five seconds so
let's see this is time zero this is five
seconds so if we look at if we look at
the hares position after five seconds so
after five seconds so after time equals
five seconds it does indeed look like
the hares position the hares just
sitting there at the 90 the 90 foot
marker line and is not moving at all the
rate of change of position with respect
to time for the hare at that point is
zero so this does seem true it just
doesn't apply to the question it's not
the meaning of the rate of change of T
of T on this interval this is applying
to H of T the hare runs at a speed of 18
feet per second for the first five
seconds so let's see if this is true for
the first five seconds so this is five
seconds going by the hare is able to
cover a distance the hare is able to
cover a distance of 90 feet so the hare
is able to go 90 feet in five seconds so
for the first five seconds first five
seconds the hair is hares rate is 90
feet you could say average rate of
change is 90 feet in five seconds and
ninety divided by five is indeed
eighteen feet feet per second so once
again this third statement is true it
just doesn't apply to T of T it's not
addressing the question now the fourth
choice is that the hare wins the race
now winning the race had to get to 100
feet in the shortest amount of time this
is a hundred feet right over here so
let's see so it looks like only the
tortoise even gets to that point after
20 seconds the tortoise gets to the
hundred foot mark the hare is still
hanging around taking a nap or something
at 90 feet
so this is actually outright false the
tortoise wins the race so we will
definitely go with our first choice